the remains of 30 victims of the
sebranitza genocide are being buried on
the 28th anniversary of the atrocity
thousands in Bosnia and Herzegovina are
paying tribute to the dead more than 8
300 remaining Muslim men and boys were
killed by Bosnian Serb forces during the
Balkans War the remains of many victims
were found later in Mass Graves which
were hidden to try to cover up war
crimes well let's bring in Ida hajimusid
she joins us live now from sebraniza Ida
why is this process of search and
identification taking so long
while firstly not all victims have been
found and identified in the cerebral
genocide more than 8
300 men boys and thousands of women were
killed but thousands are still still
missing while the Bosnian Serb military
and Army in July 1995 they killed these
people they buried them in Mass Graves
and it took them months to later
excavate The Remains and to bury them in
other locations in other sites they were
using heavy machinery and bulldozers and
this is precisely the reason why is it
is still very very hard to find and
identify these remains for example I'm
standing here in the cemetery where
until now thousands of victims have been
buried so far but in the vast majority
of cases their skeletons are incomplete
sometimes there is only one single bone
in their coffin for example even the
youngest victim a boy a 15 year old boy
who was killed in 95 who will be buried
here today his remains will be buried
incomplete he will be buried without his
skull without his hand and other parts
of his body I had a 28 years is a very
long time to wait talk us through what
you're now hearing there from the
families
foreign
obviously it is very hard for the
families even almost 30 years on firstly
there are families who still haven't
found and identified their loved ones it
is very hard for them because with time
hopes are fading there are some families
who managed to find and identify only
parts of remains of their loved ones and
they still uh don't want to bury them
because they're hoping they will find
the rest of their bodies in the future
but even for the families who managed to
find identified and bury their loved
ones who have a side to mourn them like
the one here in srebrenitza they also
feel very disappointed because the
perpetrators keep denying genocide which
was ruled by the icj and the
international Court in Hague as genocide
and also there is a genocide denial ban
brought by the former High
representative of Bosnia of the
International Community in Bosnia who is
in charge to monitor the peace agreement
and it is illegal in the country to deny
the genocide but despite this fact this
crime is still being denied
they're reporting live from sebraniza
thank you very much Ida